they may not have the numbers or the
firepower to match but soldiers on
ukraine's front lines feel they have
something the enemy can't muster
they're fighting for money for the ideas
of some crazy people they're demoralized
we're at home defending our homes our
children our parents we have no place to
escape to
and in these defensive positions on the
outskirts of the capital kiev
they have something else too
support for the underdog the sympathy of
foreigners who've traveled here to
ukraine to become comrades
i'm [ __ ] in your fighting for
democracy
because of
democracy is precious
and one man couldn't decide that another
country shouldn't have it
at a checkpoint in the capital tiles are
filled with old soviet era tomes and
textbooks the reservists on duty say
they'll use the books to set the
barricades alight if they have to
soviet history has not been kind to
ukraine but here it has its uses the
mayor of kiev is here too vitaly
klitschko not a man who needs reminding
how to fight
there is fighting in butcher european
hostile at this moment
the one thing i can say that we won't go
anywhere from kiev every house every
street every checkpoint will fight to
death if necessary
russian forces are less than 30
kilometers to the west of kiev video
released by the russian ministry of
defense shows its ground forces in
apparently robust form though western
intelligence reports say they've made
little progress towards the capital in
recent days
russia does have a significant air force
capable of causing serious harm over
large
areas
but still functioning ukrainian air
defense systems
a surprise to many
continue to contain it
[Music]
as the war grinds on mercilessly it is
punctuated with occasional bouts of
diplomacy a third round of talks has
been held by ukrainian and russian
negotiators on the belarussian border
but with neither side willing to give
ground it's unclear what there is to
discuss besides ceasefires that don't
seem to hold
a unilateral offer by russia to open
humanitarian corridors out of some of
the worst areas of bombardment and to
ferry people to safety in belarus and
russia itself was denounced by the
ukrainian government as unacceptable and
immoral but it did herald a period of
relative calm in urpin on the outskirts
of kiev
heavy shelling killed eight civilians
here on sunday but monday saw many
people making their escape
my feeling is that
i'm afraid about tomorrow i'm gonna
fight about now what i heard about
tomorrow what will happen ukraine next
what's the next day
what's our future here
no one knows what the future will bring
if russian forces do mount a ground
assault on the capital it will likely be
through these western outskirts for the
city's defenders the only certainty is
that the battle for ukraine is happening
now
behind the lines another army is hard at
work
volunteers contributing in every way
they can to the war effort cutting
stitching knotting turning strips of
cloth into camouflage netting you hear a
great deal about the unexpected strength
of ukrainian resistance about the
bravery of its soldiers the example set
by its leaders the civilians who've
taken up arms and joined the front line
well this this
is no less a part of it
civilians soldiers fighters and
survivors
the finally woven fabric of a nation
under attack joe nahol al jazeera ulviv